that went too far
what chicken sauce
it just gets so much worse no you've got
parents
not reading that you guys dug for the
worst ones didn't you
can shop okay
breathe Tom Ellis can shove jelly beans
up my ass any goddamn day he wants and
can punch me in the face thank you
foreign
beans up inside you and I punch them in
your face to get them out again sort of
like a sort of Primal vending machine I
like it I want to bend Richard Madden
over who is here make him Arch his back
and wreck him like an iron fist going
through a wet sheet of paper I do hope
my mother isn't watching any of this sit
on my face and creep in my cheeks I
actually did mail goof it's what I force
air into my call and exhale it
like a dragon's breath I would let
Suds I would
I would let Aubry Plaza poke my eyeball
out with a fork and step on my throat
with boots with nails on them and if it
pleased her well you know what it does
please me sick you were all sick sick
little babies and you all need to be
stabbed stomped on yeah Tiffany Harris
let me lick that mole off your face Ma
how how rough is that that's gotta be
like a cat tongue to lick your moan off
huh this man is trying to eat you wrong
eat me wrong each no I didn't say that I
want to suck Machine Gun Kelly saw
through his dick and then spit it back
in my face oh my God what the [ __ ]
poetic very poetic I would let Beck from
Victorious break my back like a glow
stick
[Laughter]
oh that's so visceral I would let Shawn
Mendes teeth not reading that
I'm sorry there's a line then she
crossed it Shawn Mendes I would run a
marathon Barefoot on Legos while nope
not reading that either
not reading that one I have a lot of
Dreams where I make out with Nick Kroll
and they're always a little weird but my
parents walking in on us making out is
by far the weirdest and this is a peek
into my psyche folks it really is I only
make out with people when their parents
can walk in the room which makes it hard
when you make out with someone who have
like old parents because then they're
like you have to like figure out a way
to make out in their hospital and the
look of shock and excitement on that
hospital bedridden old parents face is
what turns me on the most I would suck
Bella Porsche's butt plug like a
pacifier like a pacifier sucks suck
ew it's official I'm just a hole for
maluma
oh my God I think we're done with that
that went too far thank God vechner
isn't real because what if I start
moaning while he's sucking a life out of
me
there's so much to that that's a very
smart tweet because that's multi-layered
I get my girl to call me Bremen Rock
while we
Hardware apartment Park harder yo Noah
AKA Luke James can get this face ride
with his fine self you lucky I'm down
with the shits okay you come on ride
don't get it Hydraulics and all you feel
me put your ass in a coma I got my
Invisalign in too you ready y'all won't
get nasty I'll get nasty with you just
want to put this out there Jennifer
Coolidge is a icon
thank you Gary she has enough big energy
to power a small town that's the nicest
thing anyone's ever said to me I really
want Jay Park to rule my [ __ ] life I
wanted to I wanted to control everything
I do and keep a damn GPS on me I'll stay
on my knees forever
oh my gosh these these I could be a very
very bad man if I wanted to but I'm a
very nice guy I'm gonna get Nick Jonas's
face tattooed on my left ass cheek so I
can say I sit on Nick Jonas's face all
the time it's pretty clever actually
which facial expression would you like
to uh have tattooed on this one please
hold
or this one
I think the second because then maybe
the other thumb will come up depending
on what you're doing back there
finger me like you're manually rewinding
a VHS tape isn't that like this and then
turning yeah you want to be churned like
butter for like a long time all these
Horrors are gonna clip these of us
responding to their tweets and then just
and then actually jerk off to them I
just watched it go with me to see
Alexander literally choke a guy with his
legs do me next Daddy
wait you choked the guy with your legs
yeah but like not sexually
I didn't think it was and bonds let me
eat that ass like a sausage McGriddle
with extra maple syrup I tear that [ __ ]
up I'd say slump on that do you feel me
your knees could be the apple pie on the
side I'd Munch Munch Munch that and wash
it down with a cold glass of my Tears oh
that took a turn
no you've got parents David dobrik
please let me suck like I've seen this
exact tweet David dobrik please let me
suck the [ __ ] out of your tip drop by
drop like a hamster ran into my throat
so hard that I throw up and force me to
lick the vomit off your balls but [ __ ]
me in front of a church spit in my mouth
and nut in me then lick it out of me
show me how you squirt I've seen this
one and I want to favorite it but I know
it's a bad look but I [ __ ] appreciate
you you work hard and you're gonna get
places Jordan you want to come read this
one what if my manager read this to me
Jordan come on in wow it is extremely
specific
Beast breathtaking it would be so flush
sure to wax every once in a while I
relax all the time poor skin would be
silky
I gotta go it just gets so much worse
and that's saying so much for me I say
these words like super on The Daily in
bed but I'm sorry sweetie that's not
happening I hate to let you down but I
don't have a dick thanks for having me
BuzzFeed
[Music]
[Music]